Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Hey,
do you guys think that the economy,
Mcgregor,
Floyd Mayweather thing is,
is all a hoax and just a way to get Connor to have people talking about him
until he has his next fight,
like do you think that's just a big huge thing?
Secrets Marketing ploy?
I think the world's flat too.
You think it's real?
I think me and Jill Bolte don't want to talk about,
I think we're both red in the face.
No,
I think,
no.
I mean do you think is a good album box is going to happen?
It's going to be what's going to happen?
It's going to happen.
It's so close.
No,
I'm telling you,
this is why I don't talk to him.
There is a contract to a new podcast called the fighter and the man,
listen to me.
She's too confusing.
Time tracked.
Loosen the UFC and Connor verde come to an agreement right now you update them
because right now they're in negotiation with the Floyd Mayweather team.
So Floyd Mayweather team is going to want an exorbitant amount of money.
They're very patient.
They're going to take a long time to draw this out so they can get the best
deal.
But essentially the UFC and Connor have come to some sort of promotional
agreement and now they have to figure out how much money Floyd gets and whether
or not they want to gamble on giving him a flat rate of like a hundred million
dollars.
Whatever the fuck he wants.
That's a big whether that's a big like if,
yeah,
but he's also going to want a piece of the pie.
Correct.
They'll be not close to a contract yet.
They're not close,
but they're 90% that's what I'm saying is that I feel like,
oh,
and then so,
so what happens?
They don't,
don't pretend that you have any knowledge of this.
Just do everybody a favor.
I'm yourself.
That's my theory.
Do yourself a favor and don't let your mouth get ahead of life theory that I
believe this is a very smart way of keeping him in align lighter.
That's by the way,
let me ask you this.
When,
when,
um,
Tony Ferguson,
and let's just say Tony Ferguson sending Khabib fight before that and now,
now somebody is waiting to fight.
Conor,
will Conor fight those guys before he fights Floyd?
No,
definitely not.
So then what happens to the money?
The money right now is in Floyd versus Connor Connor.
And it's just exorbitant money.
Like he might make,
who knows how many fucking millions of dollars,
maybe a hundred.
Right?
So that's where the real money is for Floyd.
And this is where the real money is for Connor.
So for Connor to jeopardize that by fighting that fucking Russian savage or Tony
Ferguson who also could beat him,
I mean,
I'm not saying he's going to,
but it the off Tony Ferguson is a motherfucking world champion caliber fighter.
So is Habib.
That's a fucking killer fight.
So,
but we don't even know if Khabib can even make one 55 anymore,
man.
He says,
he says he can influence by October.
Right?
Of course there was,
he says he can,
but he didn't make it.
Not only did he not make it this fucking liver shutting down and you had to go
to the Goddamn hospital.
Did you die?
Can we use like,
did you die?
Almost,
but did you die?
Did you tie it?
Hey,
get up there and make 55 so I can fucking eat my popcorn.
And you fight Tony Ferguson,
but did you die or you did not get the fuck up there and make the weight for my
entertainment?
I just need one fight out here.
But did you die?
Could beam,
who's that?
Ken?
Yeah,
Ken.
John,
yeah.
Okay.